[Music]
all right we got a patron submitted
article today by none other than kuya
Kua hey Kua what's up what's up submit
some articles to us we will filter it
because some of them wild but really
make sure you join our patreon all right
so that kuya means brother it doesn't
mean brother
um there's a dude named Bobby Crawford
right and this guy's got a problem for
sure he be taking drugs but some of you
guys might know him he actually used to
be a former football and or soccer
player depend on yeah you you remember
him yeah I I'm I'm big into uh the
leagues are you yeah yeah what's your
favorite League you know the Manchester
City the um G League you really follow
Manchester uh yeah dude [__]
Manchester United right look I can't
stand watching soccer hey I'm going be
real Liverpool all the way so Manchester
I get it I get it but like the World Cup
the World Cup was lit the World Cup was
lit that [__] was great that sh was fun
cuz there's something on the line but
then some soccer games I'm like World
Cup of anything when I see it this you
know I don't like that I like to whack
too much but I'm born into a Liverpool
family I have to do it Liverpool is
that's cool that must I'm married into I
bet if you're a part of a a soccer
family that must be fun but if where
there's like so much pride in Grandin
that you you can like kind of like
swallow the culture if you're just
watching it like just there it's like
very slow sometimes it's not
entertaining for me yeah we'll probably
get hate for that but there's this ex
semipro footballer named uh Bobby
Crawford who has you just say soccer
player cuz you're throwing me off cuz
you make me think of someone masculine
and not feminine I
think you keep throwing me off dude okay
soccer you want me to say soccer yes
soccer okay soccer player and and and
say it say it with a snaky
s player okay that's more a player too I
could [__]
but he's got a drug problem what kind of
drugs uh cocaine that's popular that be
the worst drug problem yeah it's not
that bad damn get a lot done you can you
get cocaine comeback he's probably
gooded I want to try that doing
Athletics I bet it's helpful [__] wait
what you think it's like a you think
it's a better pre I never got into Coke
I never I never tried Coke so I don't
even know how it feels I feel like Coke
would be too good for me I I used to
pride myself in someone who's done every
single drug in the world except for
shrooms and then came out IA came out
DMT came out [__] well cocaine was
just shunned upon I smoke crack but
never any Coke and I said man I'm
there's all of these that I can't claim
anymore have you never done mushrooms no
that shit's scary I did a lot ofd do
mushrooms how did you skip Coke and go
to crack like how did you crack was more
accessible it's cheaper it is cheaper
it's more Street like I did [__]
Street [__] you know like I'd [__]
yeah he that blue collar drug you know
what I mean got it I the
Windex
right well this dude Bobby Crawford uh
he actually ended up smashing a woman's
head against the floor lifted her up by
the vagina and kicked her between the
legs because he took so much cocaine
that he thought that there was another
man hiding inside her vagina see I think
this is a soccer he [__] lifted her
with her vagina that's [__] he grabbed
her by the [__] that's crazy oh [__]
for real lifted her by it her injuries
were from uh rough consensual sex oh my
Lord there's got to be more than Coke in
there dude this guy is like I want to
blame it I know it's drugs but like my
gut instinct is what did she do no no no
no that's not what I'm saying my gut
instinct is to blame his actions not on
the drugs but the fact that he's a
soccer player yeah full circle I was
going to blame it on his feminine side
yeah I'm like this guy sounds like a
little F dud are a problem man I feel
like if he got if he got you know like
real hit like hit more often he probably
wouldn't do [__] like that rugby guy
would never do that no I don't know oh I
have a question is this the seating
arrangement always like yeah sometimes
what makes you want to ask that I love
this table you like our table stupid the
hot this is the hot take table it's
called the believe all women table is it
believe all women um man I think yeah I
just if you were to if you were to base
off your personality which side would
you yeah where would you sit bro you
have to like adopt the I mean I'm on all
three it depends which is probably why
you're sitting here huh in the middle
we're the good looking table Yeah the
hot sex hav sex sex table yeah for sure
that's why you're sitting here later no
way sex do this with your hat do this
with your
hat reverse too the [__] is that that's
[__] ambis seex that's what you do
when you wear that kind of hat you go
and you say something like I'm not a sex
and you do that all right that Co here
try SE I haven't sex in a really long
time do it show us how it's done which
side the front side it doesn't matter oh
noix
it it just went up to you're like I
don't have sex very you know what I mean
come on you actually look good D thank
you I feel like it's too big for my head
all try the hat but you got to say the
line you got to say the line ni looks
like he's going on a Safari Adventure
hey that's swaged outo say say the line
say the line I'm a
sex you look likeable you look like you
you're you're like very wealthy from
working in the railroads nice nice nice
railro you wear hats like that
already that looks just that looks
correct you look like D I like horses
yeah yeah in the black and white photo
that looks good oh my God work on that
railroad hit the railroad oh you're a
blu's brother or from the Outback i'
rather masturbate than [__] you je and
somehow that's a disc coming from Joe
look at that
yeah that hurts that's a true alpha
male yeah so he lifted her by the vagina
yeah yeah that's crazy I don't have lice
by the way dude that's [__] nuts man
that's actually nuts there are certain
times though when people just lose their
[__] [__] and I'm all like you were
probably not on marijuana you're
probably on like five different
marijuana don't make you do that ever
but there's people that claim that [__]
or the news will be like a man deranged
on marijuana but what about girlfriend's
face you know is this typical Like
Cocaine Behavior new spent all life
cocaine if anything just heightens
something else that's what I'm saying
see say it's not like when you hit
cocaine suddenly you you're angry if
you're already
angry or if you're already a stupid
little [__] boy soccer player then yeah
like Wall Street he's like this he's
goes W like what's that woo feeling but
that's not anger it's a up so imagine
that's a fun guy all right imagine
taking your pre-workout right but in
your pre workout you condense all that
energy to 15 minutes and imagine just
snorting that and it hits you right away
are you sold damn so he just I'm start
working out on okay kind of you might
your but last 15
minutes introducing it our new secret
ingredient that's exactly what people do
they they're constantly taking bumps or
lines all night that's the dangerous
thing about Coke it's like it's so quick
and that's why people just keep re girls
in K Town girls is their they love every
girl in K Town really girls love Coke in
the bathroom
like no but people in stalls people like
just come out in stalls you don't hear
that in the bathroom but you're yeah
yeah and
there he did it so good man I thought
girls in K Town like Kore and barbecue
boy was I
wrong Sesame Street ending
that I'd rather masturbate than [__] you
hey uh Devil's Advocate though on the
wording is lifting someone by the [__]
like only something that happens
definitively when you're doing a regular
throw on a woman cuz that's a technique
for throwing guys I imagine it's like
you know those guys that do this they do
this yeah I imagine it was something
like what would be the most technical
way to go about how do it I think it's
more like a bowling ball though where
the fingers are inside oh my God yeah
yeah yeah yeah cuz you know how strong
it have to be like pick up a chick like
that SP you got a Spiderman you got to
scoop grip the bottom yeah cuz isn't
that like a way to lift yeah let me try
to Firefighters would rescue you that
way but then you would consider that let
me my ball imagine lifting like this
dude that's
hard I can do it like this like high
crot like a high crotch like you like
that okay so so that's that might be
lifting it but imagine if you did the
same thing cing his balls did he do it
with one hand I'm cing his balls though
making sure that there's a full grip
around his that's true cuz they never
say stuff like lifting him by his yeah
if it's two guys fighting they don't say
like imagine getting lifted by your sack
oh [__] oh like pulled up like that yeah
yeah grabbing it Bud if it's on me good
luck trying to get a good grip you know
what I
mean what were you saying Anthony Le
it's cold dude it's just high and tight
that's all this guy has had a historical
like domestic abuse kind of situation
with this chick that he's had a
relationship with same girl yeah girl
you need to leave him beat her many
oh she's not going anywhere they're
stuck together but then there was one
time that he was just [__] up he was
like high on coke and stuff she got a
notification on her phone or a message
from some dude but this guy thought that
it was a love rival but it was her uncle
a love rival is that what you call it
that's that's that's what saying happy
birthday [__] love rival we got to start
saying and there are instances where
like he was so crazy that he thought
that she was hiding him in like the
mattress so he would like cut up and rip
up the mattress like check the CL flip
things over and then one time the most
recent time he was so [__] possessed
in some weird way that he thought that
he was hiding in her vagina that's what
he said that's what I mean man these
dgas are vagina all like hey
[__] I know you're in there yeah
[__] I'll come get you that was
his explanation he was like this will
get me a the guy is the like has like
the iPhone flash you got 30 seconds come
out dark there's no dude on Earth that's
completely normal and then has a day
like that like this guy was on a ramp
and all of these points she should have
left [__] snat and honestly at that
point to you can't even blame the
cocaine no you can't that's an activator
he's nuts he's giving cocaine a bad rap
honestly I think this guy's it's not
cocaine this guy's [__] nuts this guy
look at him look at him yeah let me see
a picture day Traders everywhere are
pissed this guy stupid yeah look that
guy he played soccer dude
D that guy would look in a possessed
[__] a possessed [__] but like anybody
with crazy ass traits like that like if
he's going that far at that point his
rap sheet domestically must be fre a
circus oh yeah oh for sure you guys want
to see the
girl why'd you go
uh kind of cute yeah I like her cute the
shave sides are in bro like that's a
that's a long on top shave sides that's
not [__] he that photo I don't even
know that looks old dude that's probably
20198 it's hot dude that's a very good
LinkedIn profile where did you find that
Nas [__] certification you can't
Google my name like that it's [__] up
what dude I just looked up
vagina that's what they call
me